how much fentanyl does someone need to
have before it counts as drug
trafficking that's the question before
State lawmakers today they're
considering two different bills one
creates a crime of fentanyl trafficking
at 100 grams that's in line with
trafficking laws for other drugs but
attorney general Aaron Ford says it
should start as low as four grams
because just a small amount can kill
drug is dangerous
this is not a moral Crusade against drug
use
it is a crusade to save the lives of our
fellow nevadans
we cannot stand outly by and do nothing
the ACLU and Progressive groups
testified against the bill comparing it
to crack cocaine laws in the 80s and 90s
four grams would be several dozen pills